hi guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're gonna talk about the highest
vitamin C food on the planet can you
guess what it is I'm gonna wait until
you type down and I'll wait for your
answer right I'm just kidding I'm going
to tell you right now no it's not lemons
it's not bell peppers it's not mangoes
sauerkraut did you realize that cabbage
a cup of cabbage has only 30 milligrams
which is not bad a vitamin C but when
you've per mint it into sauerkraut
it has 700 milligrams per per cup this
stuff is gold a bell pepper which is
high in vitamin C this one right here
has 90 milligrams of vitamin C okay the
RDA for vitamin C is 90 milligrams per
day so you could do one of these and get
all your vitamin C or you can do a cup
of sauerkraut and get enough for the
whole week it's incredible two lemons
equal about 90 milligrams so you can do
that lemon juice you'd have to consume
about about five or six ounces of lemon
juice to get all your vitamin C because
love the vitamin C is in the outer
portion not necessarily just the juice
the other cool thing about sauerkraut is
4 to 6 ounces contain over a trillion
bacteria it's the most powerful
probiotic like for example if you have
16 ounces of sauerkraut that would be
equivalent to 8 bottles of probiotics of
a hundred pills each so it has
incredible immune building properties I
highly recommend get some sauerkraut
start including it in your diet alright
thanks for watching hey you probably
already subscribed but if you haven't
press this little button down below and
I will keep you updated